the state department has decided that
the keystone xl pipeline would not serve
the national interests of the united
states
i agree with that decision i am pleased
to announce the official approval
of the presidential permit
for the keystone xl pipeline
in my view we've already waited too long
to deal with this climate crisis
we can't wait any longer
and we see it with our own eyes we feel
it we know it in our bones
and it's time to act it was
literally like getting kicked in the
stomach we're suffering some of us are
actually closing there's strangle
holding us they're choking us out he
does not care
if he did care keystone would be going
keystone contacted us in 2008.
so it's been 13 years of my career we've
been working on this we had one
substation
here in phillip 70 complete and the cost
of that substation was 4.5 million
and then we had another substation that
was 50 percent complete at another cost
of 4.5 million
and then biden comes along and
takes office and
destroys what we've created
so all this money
gone when you look at the grand numbers
just what it means to the electrical
cooperatives in the state at 66 million
dollars in operating revenue annually
that it's gone
not here
and then for the state that's two and a
half million dollars in lost state sales
tax
and then also to the local school
districts they're losing 1.2 million
dollars a year that would go right to
the local school districts
we had a 20-year contract sign multiply
that by 20. so it's it's absolutely
devastating to the communities here in
phillip south dakota uh we're a small
rural community
around 800 people it's a great place to
live you're in the center of the world i
mean it's it's a beautiful place
simple things go slow we don't lock our
vehicles you know we have open doors for
everyone here at the motel um i had
housed a lot of the security
and and so when we were housing them i
mean my whole bottom floor was full
of these guys i mean i mean you know for
a small place like us we have 20 rooms
um and so when half of my house because
i live here i live i live on the
property so when half of my house is
full of good people
and and i'm making money
when uh
one signature changed
an entire economical advantage for our
community
that's gone
they literally packed up within like a
week and left a year later it is still
on people's minds i mean there's this
one this will be on people's minds for
years to come
we still have poles and wires sitting
sitting in a storage yard there's a man
camp right outside town that's vacant
and i don't even know
is it 10 million dollars it took to
build and all the infrastructure to get
it there and there's tumbleweeds knee
high in there it's it's an absolute
shame transcanada came to us and uh to
rent this land there's about 80 acres in
this property uh they rented for several
years before the actual building project
started but
it was it was rented to build this camp
to house workers while they're building
the pipeline uh so it is the full setup
you know has everything from
sleeping quarters to a kitchen uh a
firmery
um
even a laundry mat
it's set up for housing as well as uh
trailer hookups for people can bring
their own housing this is one of four
pipeline
locations across the country that they
would have housing set up
this is the only one that they actually
fully finished that this was ready for
people to come in and start start
construction
our little town phillips 800 people
roughly uh this was made to handle up to
1200 people every time we drive out we
are reminded of the lost opportunity uh
it's a
gorgeous site for what that was planned
to be used and and yeah to lose it was a
heartbreaker to the whole town i'm
pissed off i think we're all pissed off
because it was it's absolutely unjust
what he did i mean this is this is the
united states of america christ it's not
a dictatorship
all the facts and the data prove
that this was viable this should have
went through our own department of
transportation on the government website
has all the facts and figures they will
tell you that transporting oil by
pipeline is much safer than either doing
a by rail car or by truck or by waterway
barge it's
the only reason it was canceled was
purely political i think it shocked
everybody that when when
this was
government or you know political
proclamation to say it's okay to build
it they invest the money into it then
all of a sudden you pull the plug we are
the collateral collateral damage our one
chance in a lifetime to to get some
opportunity some growth to lower our
rates for our members and he took it
away from us i'm terrified
that in within 10 years if we don't get
the right kind of leadership
in washington and if we don't really
start thinking about what's happening to
us economically we don't really button
up our genes here we're
toast phillip will die and it'll be just
another little ghost town in the middle
of nowhere that nobody gave
you know what about